with a spectator quote calling it now  the Democrats are running Beto and  Abrams in 2024. it's just so insane how  they're gonna they're gonna do this  what do they have name name one person  Oprah and  Oprah and Michelle that's what I think I  think yeah they're gonna run and then  that's it I mean I mean beta house can  you beat them we got donut operator beta  work tweeted hell yes we're gonna take  your AR-15 in uh September of 2019 and  then he just tweeted good luck he's not  gonna take anything now thank goodness  but he should take a nap yeah he's gonna  take a nap I think he's the I think he's  the Democratic nominee for 2025 really  yeah but how they had he has nothing to  run on where's the experience where's  him being in some kind of political  office where he made a difference what  can he run on other than Iran and lost  and was embarrassed they might run him  along with a bunch of other people like  they did like Stacy Abrams again they  lost  um Pete bootage